hey guys this is andrew for
trendsenses.com so for those who don't
yet i've been working as a professional
trader for the past six years in hong
kong and right now i'm doing youtube
videos
where i mostly talk about technical
analysis which is a set of tools that i
use every day to build up my scenarios
and to set up my trails
so if you guys want to know about how
this is working and to learn how to do
it yourself
you are in the right place so today i
want to make an update on gamestop
let's get into it
[Music]
so i'm gonna try to make this video as
short as possible but there are a lot of
things to say
so i'm gonna keep it organized and let's
start
with analyzing the different indicators
we're having and see what kind of
signals they are giving us
then we're gonna build up the different
scenarios using idiot wave theory
and then we're gonna try to choose which
scenario is
most likely to happen we start as usual
on the forest time frame
so forget about the drawings just
focus on the moving averages 200
50 20. what do you see
all right i'm gonna help you guys what
you see is that the 200
moving average which is the most
important one is
lower it is not tested
so it doesn't have any strong
information once again this is the most
important one
it's not giving us any signal here we're
having the 20
that is here giving us some support
and it just has been broken on the four
hours time frame
broken confirmed so what we
saw on the last hours of training of
wednesday yes i'm in asia that's why i'm
you know
just thinking about is it wednesday or
thursday but whatever
so on wednesday session in the us is
actually
bearish just on the short term first
information but
it's obtained using the 20 period moving
average which is
not that you know trust
you cannot trust this you know 100 so
you go back on the daily and you do the
same thing guys the exact same thing
i've just done you look at the moving
averages
and once again the 203 moving average is
really really far away at 50
so it will not give us any good signal
and we're having
the price action contained between the
20 and the 50.
so the 50 is acting as support you can
see here
tested but right away we came back
tested we closed the both guys we closed
above we closed on this one
at 140.99
so it is but you can see it's visual it
is above the
50 period moving average so the price
action is contained here
so we are having you know and they're
gonna converge very soon guys
so we're having something like this and
the price
might do something like this so this is
one scenario but once again i don't
build my scenarios using moving averages
i just use them to see if we are bullish
or bearish
right now i'm done with the moving
averages
the only information i have is that it
looks bearish on the short term
but the information is obtained using a
moving average that is definitely not
the best
so it's kind of an information to use
but
you need to discount it maybe a little
bit then
second thing that we're using guys
you know what i'm gonna do because i
always do it
it's trend lines guys i love trend lines
streamlines are giving
me really really good signals they
usually you know break out signals like
you break it you retest it you can buy
the breakout put a stop loss right below
for day trading like me it is very very
clear and nice signals to use to make
money
so what do we have here you can do trend
lines everywhere
you just need to connect highs and lows
here i'm wondering if this a b
c like w x y because you know
w and y contain abc so once again for
those who want to know
more about idiots just click on the link
in the description of this video
and you're going to access the member
zone where for now only put one training
about illiot but i'm going to put many
more
very soon and i explain everything guys
about how idiot wave counting is working
through rules that you need to apply to
have valid counting and
what information this can bring you and
trust me it can bring you a lot of
information if you know
how to use it but you need to practice
so here
my abc that is here might be finished so
if it is finished we gonna have a
breakout ultimately be
you know at the end of any wave we see
a breakout and the breakout is very
easy to identify but sometimes it's
going to be a fake breakout
you know that's true but here do we have
a breakout guys on the forward time
frame
do we have a breakout i'm asking you i
told you in the video i did a few days
ago
i told you guys that we're looking you
know to break the level around you know
165
and that we having the 175 horizontal
trend line
that is you know once again obtained
like here here here
here you know many clean reactions all
right those are not clean but
this this and this is very clean and the
175
level and here you can see we got
rejected guys at 175 it's not a surprise
it's a pivot point guys it's a it's a
level
it's like a moving average that is
stable if we are above it's good if we
are below it's not good
right now we are below so what you guys
are looking for
is a breakout of this level but before
that we're gonna have a breakout of this
this signal to me is actually better
because i believe the market is
developing in waves
so i'm looking for a signal of
completion of a wave
and i'm gonna have the signal when we
break this so here we had
this is not a breakout all right this is
not a fake breakout because there is no
breakout here
this was the price action was trying to
break out but
ultimately we closed below and of course
we didn't confirmed something that
didn't happen
because it didn't even happen in the
first place so right now we're trading
below guys
so here we are below the moving average
but
actually what we want to see is
something like this all right
this is what we're looking for this is
breakout here breakout here
and then we're gonna be bullish but
we're not having this yet
and my conclusion about trend lines
is that we are bearish on the short term
because the price action is trending
below
this so once again guys this can shift
very soon in
two candles the shift can occur and i've
just shown you how it would
work it would be like this breakout
re-test
so don't panic if you see a breakout we
can still buy the re-test
ninety percent of the time every test
occur ten percent of the time there is
no retest
so keep this in mind so i'm done with
moving averages i'm done with strain
lines i'm gonna try to look for
divergences
like uh you guys probably saw if you
like anc as well
that we have beautiful divergences on
amc let's see
if we're having the same on game stuff
because the price action is actually you
know
very correlated so i go on a daily time
frame
and i check so a hidden divergence was
here on amc we were making
higher lows but the macd was going
lower is the magnitude going over here
it's going from here
to here no it's going higher so we don't
have any divergence on the long term
which doesn't mean that we are not
bullish it just means that
this signal is not given so we are
looking for other signals but here
it's not bearish as well it's neutral
all right no divergence that's it
then on the forward time frame we had a
divergence so let me very quickly remind
you guys what our divergence is
all right so a bullish divergence we're
looking for this we're having both of
them on amc
price action making higher lows momentum
indicator making
lower lows so this is for example the
magazine and this is your price
and a regular divergence is the price
action going lower
and the macd making higher lows so this
means that
the momentum is actually an early signal
of the price action reversal
because we're making lower lows but with
less power and this means that
despite the very strong bearish momentum
that we have in the market
with the mighty going lower the price
action is holding
and making a higher low so both of this
information
are bullish divergences so we don't have
it on the daily now let's go on the
forest time frame and let's see we're
having one on amc
here we have a regular divergence so we
have the price action going
lower like this and the macd going
higher so do we have it here 26th of
march
26th of march and this is 13th of april
we don't have it let's be honest we
don't have it price action going lower
magdi going lower no divergence so
for now moving averages bearish on the
short term
trend lines bearish on the short term no
divergence so neutral
so we are having either w x
y so the the y cannot go here you
understand guys the y
needs to go at least as low as the x so
if
the wxy correction is in place
we're going to go to 110 so this is one
of the scenarios
or we're not having a wxy we had an abc
and we are doing a one two three four
five
so this is possible as well but for that
we need to break out
here i'm kind of neutral you know
because let's see a bit
the news so the news is for example
gamestop shares saw after ceo departure
news
roaring kitty doubles stake so i'm not
going to go through this here
but basically they changed the ceo you
guys probably
know about that and the retail investors
are still believing very strongly in
this
stock and they believe that the business
model is going to change and that's
gamestop earnings are going to go better
and that basically this is a stock that
is going to go
higher so this is bullish
and let me show you something else so
this is you know more about the flows
all right yes i do technical analysis to
spot the momentum and to spot if there
is any
information in the price action
direction
and i use the news and open interest on
the option market i'm an option trader
to actually
find information about the flows and i
use both of information and here guys
you've probably seen me uh doing this
already
i take all the open interest on the call
options
that i found on yahoo finance i take all
of them
i compute their delta all right using
this formula that is here you know
so the delta is a formula like this so
it's very kind of technical but you know
i've done it so right now i can update
it very quickly
and i compute basically the total
exposure that we're having on every
strike and then i
compute the synthetic short interest
that we're having on gamestop and
i can make some scenarios to find if
there is a lot of
move in this synthetic short interest
when gamestop goes higher
and the first thing you can do guys is
that i compute the total
number of shares that we're having if
all the calls were in the money and i
have 17 million of shares
that are concentrated as you can see
guys in this column
so on the 800 strike 690 and this
number is actually growing guys and it's
huge and despite the expiry is coming it
is
at least stable so and if gamestop goes
to 200
you can see that this is growing so
we're having
as many as 17 million shares equivalent
and they're concentrated around those
strikes 200
700 and 100 and guys it's really a lot
so this is telling me that the option
market is still very active
the volatility is by the way still very
high on those options you know
and it's around 200 percent on the 800
strike so it's a lot
so this is telling me that you know the
bullish momentum is still
here so to conclude here i'm neutral i'm
having you know some bearish information
coming from my technical analysis
that are telling me that probably like
the x w x y correction
is on the table so i don't know if we're
gonna do this or if we're gonna break
out on the upside this trend line
and actually the gamma is gonna kick in
all the synthetic short is gonna you
know
make uh the market makers buying and hex
buying buying buying more shares
when gamestop is gonna trade higher and
if we break those levels here
definitely there's gonna be some
momentum coming in the macd
on the daily time frame you know is
still very negative for now
so you know i'm neutral and i'm waiting
to see
what is happening in the coming days so
that's it for me i hope you guys enjoyed
this video and if you did
please don't forget to click on the sub
like and bell button so you're gonna be
the first to know when i upload anything
new
and stay close to show see you guys